what's up guys my name is colin mcneil
for thescore esports
last valentine's day we gave you a video
called the top 10
hottest league of legends players and
you loved it
[Music]
yeah so this year we're giving you more
of what you want
with the top 10 hottest players in cs go
now
hold on before you start writing an
essay in the comment section
promising to unsubscribe hear me out
we evaluated these players based on
their highlight potential
recent success relevancy to the game
and yeah they're good looks too so now
that the criteria is out of the way
here is the top 10 hottest guys
in cs go
peanut brain i don't think so nobody
is underestimating the tactical prowess
of tarik
after cloud9's incredible major win in
boston
[Music]
and you know what i have it on good
authority that
smart is sexy that's why we picked him
to start off this entirely scientific
top 10 list it is a dance and now they
can see multiple angles
they're touching the bottom and now goes
brain another bob that is
trying to defuse it again but no
guardian gets taken down
absolutely unreal random cloud9
[Music]
ah yes the bosnian beast nico's frags
are
always hot but since joining faze clan
we feel like his style has really
improved as well
damn this dude has some swag and it's
worth noting that nico has
obviously been hitting the gym lately
we'd be doing him a real disservice
if we didn't give him props for the hard
work he's been putting in
now let's cut the shirtless selfies and
get to the good [ __ ]
those sexy nico frags here we go that is
nico
coming in the back lines takes down
chris jay all of a sudden it's flipped
around once again
two versus one the world's best player
up against it the stay in the game
they'll go for the fake defuse but nico
not taking the bait can he finish this
job
yes he can we're going at one time
oh my god in the flames as well
he dies after the kill but it doesn't
matter we reset everything and we've got
overtime how fitting that it's nico
against his old team
you know i won't lie i did not have jdm
on this list originally but some of the
women in the office
just wouldn't stand for it the bandana
wearing chair reclining american opera
had been an integral part of team liquid
since the summer of 2016.
that is until his recent departure in
february of this year
he's like the all-american boy next door
if the boy next door could hit flick
shots like this
awp push out good shot jdm looks for
another he's got this down to one versus
two
over commitment and perhaps a little bit
zealous to try and early end this
oh there is what is that from jdm
uber and hey if that didn't convince you
take a look at this bizarre video from
esg mykonos
with jdm coming out of the ocean daniel
craig style
is that
[Music]
wow
the first and only frenchman on our list
shocks
can do it all he can opt with the best
of them out duel just about anyone on
rifles
and clutch like you wouldn't believe to
increase their weight to the fight
shocks with a stunner towards nothing
and now 1v4 he needs to go above and
beyond
he needs the ace and he's going to go
for it as well 15 bullets another for
shocks
this could be absolutely sensational 1v1
against shroud the clock is taking trout
on and down and it's gonna be shots with
the ace
it's on shot [ __ ] at 103 to try and keep
it alive otherwise we'll go to a fifth
map in the grand finals
sharks tabs out one that's a deadly kill
goes for the second and he's moving
closer
looking for the quad clutch here fnx the
last man alive he's gonna tap the bomb
once
you've got to be kidding
and when it comes to matters of the
heart i like to imagine he's equally
well-rounded
everybody loves a renaissance man am i
right
and hey that suave haircut and pretty
solid jawline
don't hurt either
they say success is the best aphrodisiac
well in our next player's case he's got
plenty of that
success i mean arguably the best player
in the world
coldzera also sports one hell of a manly
mustache
that practically exudes testosterone
we're talking
tom sellick levels of manliness here
and just like nico cold has clearly been
putting in work
at the gym these days he's looking like
a lean
mean fracking machine and if you do
manage to resist the brazilian's animal
magnitude
just take a look at these highlights
much more okay to work with here he
comes once again the first base
is the trend he's going to hit the
ground there's cold
wow cold what is it going on right now
how does he do this luminosity with your
play
unthinkable scenes there on the b
apartments
[Applause]
coming in at number five is another
player that the female contingent here
in the office
just couldn't leave off the list the
clean-cut
danish superstar himself device
recently bouncing back from an injury
that kept him out of competitive
counter-strike for months
device is back as the primary offer for
danish powerhouse astralis and we
are glad to see it i have to admit i am
starting to see the appeal
all right show of handsome and handsome
all opposed
but whether he's your type or not you
just can't argue with plays like this
all on device one versus four he's gonna
get one good head shotting but
they should be able to swarm him there's
just too much here he's gonna get one
more in
taps away device looking the wrong way
tearing us out oh my lord
device taking four kills
ah sean guerrez analyst in-game leader
and not a bad fragger himself is there
anything this guy
can't do only gets the and that is
really devastating any bit of damage is
definitely very
potent here for tsm bucks it looks like
he's able to do some damage as well so
two players dead here for cloud9 but
that's not the end of the world
between leading misfits to some pretty
impressive results to appearing on the
e-league analyst desk
we've been seeing a lot of mr guerrez
recently
and that combined of course with his
good looks has landed him
at the number 4 spot on our list
they do say confidence is the key to
attraction and sean
has plenty to be confident about
you are not my friend you are my brother
my friend do i
really need to explain why pasha biceps
is on this list
this dude is swole guy looks like he
could curl a bus and a half
plus he has some absolutely adorable
children
and i know the ladies love a family man
aww oh yeah and i guess he's a pretty
good counter-strike player
as well nails it he's got a chance he's
got a chance
gets it and finds the immediate threat
takes down the planner while he's still
defenseless and kenny's gonna try and
wrap around but pasha finds that as well
that's so sick
i'm just gonna come out and say it one
taps are sexy
although he hasn't been in top form
recently scream is still the undisputed
king
of single shot and tight spray ak kills
uh sorry wrong clip but vp continue to
press forward onto the b science next
scream holding the line scream with the
triple head shot just stop and i'm cold
brings it back to two on two and he
could get the ace he's doing
i could say more about screams dashing
good looks piercing eyes and
well-groomed facial hair
but hey i think these highlights speak
for themselves
this is it people our number one hottest
cs go player and who else could it
possibly be
but the x-god himself dosia is a
living legend not just in counter-strike
but in the russian dating scene as well
his exploits in love are almost as well
known as his accomplishments in esports
a 1.6 player who successfully made the
transition to global offensive
the russian playboy is a major champion
and a major heartbreaker
[Music]
now before you get too hot under the
collar i do need to inform you that as
of september of 2017
doja is a happily married man
mortals now feeling like they know what
to do to challenge his banana position
gambit has sent even more firepower
bring more this is so smart oh this is
huge
george's throwing it into the corner
just as the ball is gonna go off they're
[Music]
over here in the event zamber gets two
this is a two on five situations that
we're talking about jojo with the 4k
and the wall bang off to finish it off
okay that was our list and you made it
this far
so go ahead flame me but i don't know
about you
i feel the energy in the air it's like
cupid one tapped me with his deagle of
love
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button